[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schenken abend und willkommen
den sport hat gleich norbert lehmann
einen schönen guten abend auch von mir
deeskalation in der russland ukraine
krise das bestimmende thema heute
putin macht ernst russlands präsident
erkennt die separatisten gebieten der
ukraine als unabhängig an und könnte
truppen in die region schicken
als reaktion stopp deutschland die
pipeline nord stream 2 auch usa und eu
kündigen sanktionen an
der konflikt hat auch folgen für die
deutsche wirtschaft gas dürfte noch mal
teurer werden
das ist der anfang einer invasion so
bewerten die usa das russische vorgehen
in der ukraine vor wenigen stunden wurde
vom oberhaus in moskau auf antrag von
präsident putin ein militäreinsatz in
der ost ukraine zugestimmt ein weiterer
schritt nach der anerkennung der
separatisten gebiete gestern schauen wir
auf die ost ukraine als unabhängig
anerkannt hat russland nicht nur die
bisher vom prorussischen kräfte
gehaltenen gebiete sondern die ganzen
region lohans und dann jetzt sie werden
von separatisten als volksrepublik
beansprucht doch sie sind ukrainische
staatsgebiet denn das könnte putin nun
truppen schicken christian sen
diese bilder sollen russisches militär
zeigen dass sich bereits in don jetzt
befindet das behaupten auch die
separatisten verifizieren lässt sich das
nicht
seit gestern nacht feiern sie in bonn
jetzt die anerkennung ihrer
unabhängigkeit
russland hurra der dank geht nach moskau
für uns ist das sehr wichtig wir wollen
als eine große familie zusammen mit
russland leben ich weiß nicht wie gut
die entscheidung ist und ob sie uns zum
frieden führt
wladimir putin hat gestern fakten
geschaffen mit dem dekret erkennt
russland die unabhängigkeit der
separatisten gebiete an heute folgte die
bestätigung durch das russische
parlament eine stunde wetterte putin
gestern die ukraine sei integraler
bestandteil der russischen geschichte
und er sprach dem land die
daseinsberechtigung ab die ukraine sei
abhängig vom westen
ist den ukrainern klar wie irland
geführt wird erkennen sie dass ihr land
noch nicht einmal ein politisches oder
wirtschaftliches protektorat ist sondern
auf einer kolonie mit marionettenregime
geschrumpft ist
die anerkennung der unabhängigkeit ist
auch ein bruch der minsker
friedensvereinbarungen für die ost
ukraine von 2015 heute blickt putin noch
mal nach und gibt der ukraine die schuld
dass münster abkommen war schon tot
lange vor der gestrigen anerkennung der
volksrepublik 'nimm dollars nicht durch
unsere schuld oder die der
repräsentanten dieser republik sondern
durch die handlungsweise der jetzigen
staatsmacht in kiew
im süden russlands im gebiet roßdorf
gibt es truppenbewegungen in richtung
separatisten gebiete russland hat mit
der anerkennung gestern auch
militärische unterstützung zugesagt
offiziell aber ist der befehl noch nicht
erfolgt das könnte putin aber jederzeit
tun
uns in moskau ist anna feist anna hat
putin jetzt den weg bereitet für eine
russischen invasion einen russischen
einmarsch in die ukraine
zumindest hat er vor wenigen minuten
eine entscheidung getroffen die so
schnell erstmal nicht für entspannung
sorgen dürfte putin hat soeben verkündet
dass er die alten grenzen der
separatisten gebiete anerkannt das
bedeutet eben die kompletten region
donetsk und oulu hans eben auch jenseits
der kontakt linie gebiete die von der
ukraine kontrolliert werden und die
befürchtung ist nun riesig das
pro-russische separatisten das als
legitimation nehmen könnten um
ukrainisch kontrolliertes gebiet
anzugreifen um ukrainische truppen
anzugreifen und an ihrer seite könnten
dann russische streitkräfte stehen der
gestern nacht wurde ja hier per dekret
entschieden dass im verteidigungsfall
russische streitkräfte die
selbsternannten volksrepublik bonn jetzt
und lohans zusammen mit den pro
russischen separatisten verteidigt
werden sollen insofern stehen die
zeichen hier erstmal nicht auf
entspannung danke für diese einordnung
an aufweist
die ukraine bittet unterdessen um
weitere waffenlieferungen von den
landweg großbritannien und erwägt die
diplomatischen beziehungen zu russland
abzubrechen von einer erhöhten
kriegsgefahr durch russland will der
ukrainische präsident selensky aber
nicht sprechen sebastian ihm mit einem
bericht aus der ukraine
trauer am morgen vor einer kathedrale in
kiew beigesetzt wird einer der beiden
ukrainischen soldaten die am samstag bei
gefechten im osten des landes getötet
wurden dafür verantwortlich sollen pro
russische separatisten sein und während
in kiew soldaten zu grabe getragen
werden versucht der präsident weiter den
spagat zwischen ruhe bewahren und
kampfbereitschaft signalisieren wir
glauben nicht an den krieg nicht an
einen großen krieg gegen die ukraine es
wird keine großangelegte eskalation von
seiten der russischen föderation geben
ist und wenn das passiert werden wir das
kriegsrecht ausrufen
unklar ist was der präsident und seine
berater für eine groß angelegte
eskalation halten wäre die schon
erreicht wenn auch die zurzeit von der
ukraine gehaltenen teile der bezirke
denn jetzt und lohans besetzt würden
oder nur bei einer breit angelegten
invasion in andere landesteile die
unsicherheit jedenfalls macht den
menschen in kiew zu schaffen sie sind
hin und hergerissen zwischen angst vor
dem einmarsch und wut auf putin
ich habe angst um meine kinder meine
enkel und alle menschen hier das was
putin und sein zirkel da machen kann zu
einem krieg führen
ich finde das nicht gut denn ist es das
territorium der ukraine nicht dass der
russen
in diesen minuten trifft sich
staatspräsident wolodimir selensky in
kiew mit den spitzen der fraktionen des
parlaments um über weitere schritte in
der krise zu beraten
und auf das vorgehen russlands reagieren
europa und die usa mit strafmaßnahmen
die bundesregierung zieht dabei nun fürs
erste die reißleine bei 1 milliarden
projekt auch wenn es für deutschland
selbst teuer werden könnte so wird die
erdgaspipeline nord stream 2 vorerst
gestoppt weitreichende sanktionen auch
von eu seite unter anderem soll der
handel mit russischen staatsanleihen auf
dem europäischen markt untersagt werden
un strafmaßnahmen gegen russische
politiker unternehmen und banken die
einzelheiten von gunnar krüger der stopp
für nord stream 2 endlich sagen viele in
europa deutschland zieht den bericht zur
versorgungssicherheit zurück es ging
zwar technisch ist aber der nötige
verwaltungsrechtliche schützt damit
jetzt keine zertifizierung der pipeline
erfolgen kann und ohne diese
zertifizierung kann trotzdem zwei ja
nicht in betrieb gehen zu dieser
sanktion kommt das paket das die
außenminister der eu in paris beraten
sie waren sowieso zusammen sprachen erst
über den indopazifik dann über den
konflikt vor der haustür ein bruch des
völkerrechts wie gestern live im
fernsehen müsse folgendes ganz oben
haben sagen die mit angst vor
wiederholung
wir kennen doch einen namen wir haben
doch alle gesichter gesehen die hinter
diesen politischen entscheidungsprozess
steht
doch ein vorschlag der eu kommission
zählt auf russische abgeordnete die
heute für die anerkennung stimmten auf
die zentralbank die im westen kein geld
mehr leihen kann und auf banken die
militär in den volks republiken
finanziert einstimmigkeit dafür vor
wenigen minuten ein stoppschild will die
eu keine eskalation keinen sanktions
wettlauf einer der nicht mehr dazu
gehört macht genau das sie erzählen
nicht nur gegen gebiete im donbass
sondern auch gegen russland um russische
wirtschaftsinteressen so hart zu treffen
wie wir kein fressens hospitant zugleich
tag die nato ukraine kommission das
bündnis will weiter hilfe leisten aber
die hauptverantwortung der nato ist
sicherzustellen dass es keinen angriff
auf einen bündnispartner
und das ist die ukraine eben nicht nicht
jetzt und wohl noch lange nicht und über
die sanktion spreche ich jetzt mit
unserem korrespondenten in washington m
at wissen und in berlin theo koll guten
abend an sie beide und fangen wir mit
ihnen am theo der kanzler hat sich ja
wirklich sehr lange zurückhaltend
geäußert was einen stopp von nord stream
2 angeht ist der druck jetzt zu gross
geworden
ja da kannst du hat jedenfalls lange
zeit viel öffentliche prügel den kauf
genommen um die pipeline bei den
sanktionsmaßnahmen nicht zu erwähnen
aber nord stream 2 ist einfach die
deutsche sanktion mit dem weltweit
höchsten symbol werde insofern ja war
der erwartungsdruck enorm hoch dazu
kommt aber eine art innere koalitions
dynamik die grünen haben das pipeline
projekt schon lange in frage gestellt
und
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck hatte
daher das rechtliche aus für die
pipeline längst vorbereitet denn die
braucht laut energiewirtschaftsgesetz
zur betriebsgenehmigung einen positiven
bericht zur sogenannten
versorgungssicherheit diese
unbedenklichkeitsbescheinigung war zwar
im oktober noch von der
vorgängerregierung erteilt worden ist
jetzt aber vom kanzler wieder
zurückgezogen worden wenn man so will
ist das also eine sanktion unter dem
deckmantel einer neuen rechtlichen
bewertung gehen wir mal die usa zu ihnen
ma die usa sprechen vom anfang einer
invasion us präsident biden will heute
abend auch eine ansprache halten zur
krise ist soll weitere sanktionen gegen
russland geben welche
joe biden will mit sanktions wellen
reagieren auf das was ich in der ukraine
da tut er hat herr gestern damit
begonnen erst mal sanktionen gegen die
abtrünnigen gebiete und gegen die
russischen unterstützer und in wenigen
minuten wird er im weißen haus wohl auch
sanktionen direkt gegen russland
verkünden zum einen gegen den russischen
präsidenten gegen sein umfeld und zum
anderen eben auch gegen große russische
banken man will die wirtschaft scharf
treffen aber gleichzeitig wird sich der
us-präsident wohl auch noch weitere
sanktionen vorbehalten um eben putin
davon abzuschrecken andere teile der
ukraine anzugreifen oder gar die
hauptstadt kiew aus dem kongress wird er
von beiden parteien gedrängt er soll
doch das gesamte instrumentarium schon
einmal vor zeigen dazu würden dann auch
sanktionen gegen den energiesektor
gehören oder ein embargo auf alle
technologischen güter die nach russland
geliefert werden auch zum beispiel güter
in denen amerikanische mikrochips
enthalten sind das könnte auch noch
kommen aber der präsident will das in
wellen tun eben um einen hebel zu haben
denn er geht davon aus dass wladimir
putin mehr will als nur die abtrünnigen
gebiete danke sie werden das weiter
fonds verfolgen nach washington und
berlin
wenn es gerade gehört die umstrittene
erdgaspipeline nord stream 2 vorerst
gestoppt aber eben auch mit konsequenzen
für deutschland was bedeutet das für die
gasversorgung her und für die ohnehin
gestiegen gaspreise mutter spiekermann
berichtet
eigentlich sollte hier schon lange gas
fließen von russland direkt nach
deutschland durch die umstrittene
pipeline nord stream 2 jetzt liegt das
projekt weiter auf eine der ersten
sanktionen gegen russland
wirtschaftsminister habeck forderte
heute erneut größere energiepolitische
unabhängigkeit und hat schlechte
nachrichten zu erwarten ist dass
militärische konflikte von indi indi ein
land eingebunden ist das ein gau der
großen gaslieferanten ist im gaspreis
nach oben treiben wird habig gibt
gleichzeitig ein versprechen
deutschland ist versorgungssicher morgen
koalitionsausschuss ohnehin auf der
agenda steigende energiepreise und
mögliche entlastungen der energiesektor
unter druck und nicht nur der angesichts
bevorstehender sanktionen die deutsche
wirtschaft warnt vor dem möglichen bruch
mit russland russland ist nach
kaufkraftparität die sechs größte
volkswirtschaft der welt kurz hinter
deutschland und wir können ja nicht nur
den bilateralen handel betrachten
sondern deutsche firmen haben auch sehr
viel in russland investiert die
verteidigungsministerin denkt hingegen
ans aufrüsten heute besuchte sie litauen
weitere truppenverstärkung denkbar auch
wir als deutschland sind bereit weitere
kräfte zu land auf dem wasser und in der
luft zur verstärkung
bereitzustellen am abend demonstration
von ukrainern vor der russischen
botschaft in berlin es sollen um die
1000 menschen seien hände weg von
unserem land ist die botschaft an
russland
putin auf kriegskurs wie reagiert der
westen dazu gibt es ein zdf spezial
gleich im anschluss aktuelle
entwicklungen finden sie außerdem
jederzeit in unserem live blog zum
konflikt in der zdf- heute
wächst sind das thema die kosten fürs
heizen steigen rasant energie sparen
lohnt sich dann nicht nur fürs klima
sondern auch für den geldbeutel ab heute
können hausbesitzer innen wieder
fördergelder für energetische
sanierungen beantragen vor einem monat
hatte die kfw die förderung gestoppt
weil ihr das geld dafür ausgegangen war
ebenso die hilfen für energiesparende
neubauten sven regn berichtet
für henning boote war es ein großer
schlag die neubauförderung für
effizienzhäuser gestoppt der traum vom
doppelhaus geplatzt dass es jetzt wieder
geld für bestehende häuser gibt nützt
ihm nichts er geht für seinen neubau
leer aus in summe werden das für ein
zweifamilienhaus 53.000 euro die fehlen
jetzt weil am 24 wurde der fördertopf
geschlossen und das bestandteil der
finanzierung gewesen und somit
mussten wir dieses vorhaben erst mal auf
eis seit heute sind nun wieder anträge
für die energetische sanierung von
gebäuden möglich die älter sind als fünf
jahre die förderungen richten sich dabei
nach den maßnahmen sprich nach dem grad
der energieeinsparung von 48.000 bis zu
75.000 euro pro wohneinheit
das ist immerhin schon mal was aber
politik lebt auch von verlässlichkeit
und vertrauen was fehlt es die
neubauförderung auf die sind viele
angewiesen und außerdem ist auch ein
hoher schaden entstanden nach unseren
berechnungen zweistelliger
millionenbetrag der jetzt fehlt gebaut
wird trotzdem nur macht sich die
fehlenden neubauförderung in der miete
bemerkbar ein euro 60 mehr pro
quadratmeter so die schätzung auch bei
altbauten hat die voerder unsicherheit
der vergangenen wochen dazu geführt dass
viele private käufer leer ausging wenn
man da jetzt zu lange überlegt
modernisiere in welchem umfang die
finanzierung ist wir haben zum teil
wirklich die gegebenheit dass verkäufer
sagen wenn du dich nicht morgen
entscheiden ist kriegt sie jemand anders
familie boote hatte übrigens glück im
bereits unterschriebenen hausbau vertrag
war eine ausstiegsklausel für den fall
dass die kfw nicht zahlt
schauen wir jetzt auf die deutschen
wälder die werden nämlich immer weniger
das zeigen satellitenfotos des deutschen
zentrums für luft und raumfahrt so sind
fast fünf prozent der waldfläche
zwischen 20 18 und 20 21 zerstört worden
schuld daran sind starke dürreperioden
und schädlingsbefall und derzeit setzen
auch noch die stürme den wäldern heftig
zu schätzungsweise eineinhalb millionen
kubikmeter holz sind auf den boden
gefallen aus dem erzgebirge berichtet
stefan kech die forstunternehmer im
erzgebirge stehen fassungslos vor
riesigen schäden es wird wochen und
monate dauern bis hier alles wieder
aufgeräumt ist
holz was wird die zukunft eben
nicht mehr hat die stürme der letzten
tage hatten allerdings auch leichtes
spiel in der vorgeschädigten monokultur
hinzu kamen dann ja noch die
besonderheit dass da wo man jetzt die
große lücke sieht
die letzten sommer im käfer schäden gab
zu dass der lücken im bestand entstanden
sind die natürlich für stabilität
gesorgt haben
nun müssen sie den wald der zukunft
einpflanzen hitzeresistent und sturm
stabil ein mischwald der dem klimawandel
trotzen kann eine schadensumme für
sachsen kann noch nicht genannt werden
wie groß die sturmschäden in den wäldern
wohl sein werden zeigt sich allerdings
schon an dieser einen talstraße bei
thermalbad wiesenbad
das sind etwa ja mindestens 500 bäume
die hier auf der fläche umgefallen sind
die ferien in sachsen gehen zu ende
diese straße muss für schulbusse
spätestens nächste woche wieder
befahrbar sein doch wo die sturmschäden
noch nicht beseitigt sind herrscht
weiterhin lebensgefahr
und jetzt kommen wir zur deutschen
frauenfußball-nationalmannschaft norbert
ja das zurzeit in wolverhampton beim
vorbereitungsturnier für die em im juli
und trifft dort morgen auf gastgeber
england kleiner vorgeschmack auf die
titeljagd im sommer im mutterland des
fußballs
ballarbeit an ungewohntem ort die
stimmung ist gut bei deutschlands besten
fußballerinnen vom klassiker gegen
england gelöste atmosphäre vom
abschlusstraining trotz bislang
durchwachsene leistung das ziel fürs
spiel morgen selbstvertrauen tanken das
gelang bislang nur bedingt ein achtbares
1 1 unentschieden gegen die spanierinnen
nach rückstand leer schiller trifft im
zweiten spiel dann eine überraschende 0
1-niederlage gegen die kanadierinnen da
ist luft nach oben gehen ja na ja immer
sehr kritisch mit uns um einen hohen
anspruch haben dann wirklich auch
permanent die chance zu haben
diese spiele dann auf diesem niveau auch
zu gewinnen die dfb frauen testen gegen
die em-gastgeber rinnen und hoffen dabei
morgen auf den einen oder anderen
volltreffer
nach der eskalation des russland ukraine
konflikts gibt es forderungen das
champions-league-finale am 28 mai im
russischen sankt petersburg zu verlegen
die uefa berät jetzt über das weitere
vorgehen einer der hauptsponsoren des
wettbewerbs ist der russische gaskonzern
gazprom
nachdem ihm die teilnahme an den
australian open verwehrt worden war hat
der serbische tennis star novak djokovic
nun seinen ersten internationalen
auftritt beim atp turnier in dubai und
hat dort sein erstes spiel gewonnen ja
und alexa das wäre der hat beim turnier
in acapulco ebenfalls gesiegt und das
achtelfinale erreicht die deutsche
nummer eins und titelverteidiger bezwang
den us-amerikaner jason brooks spiel mit
3 6 7 6 6 2 ein hartumkämpftes über
dreistündiges nacht duell das einen
neuen rekord aufstellte es endete
morgens um 4 uhr 54 kein etikett den
bislang später zu umgehen gibt aber
keine nacht zu lage ist alles im gesamt
preisgeld von 1,7 millionen dollar
erhalten nach naja
natürlich auch sagen sonnenschein viel
sonnenschein ist für morgen angesagt
mehr dazu gleich von ist intelli das
heute-journal können sie um 21 50 seen
mit christian sievers im interview der
bundeskanzler und hier geht es jetzt
direkt weiter mit dem zdf spezial zur
russland ukraine krise
ja
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter recht ungemütlich
wird es in der kommenden nacht mit regen
und schnee schnee oberhalb von 700
metern im erzgebirge oder an den alpen
auflockerungen gibt es nach nordwesten
und vor allem an den küsten sturmböen um
nordwest es wird teilweise glatz nach
westen hin bei temperaturen von null bis
minus ein grad im südwesten ist es noch
am mildesten bei sechs grad morgen gibt
es vor allem richtung rhein viel
sonnenschein und auch ganz im norden an
den alpen gibt letzte regen und
schneeschauer und das bei höchsten
temperaturen von sieben bis neun teils
12 grad im westen und 14 im südwesten
deutschlands ein schöner abend